last time I trusted someone I lost an
eye
hey everybody its charlie we're finally
getting that Colson movie crossover that
we wanted not quite in the way we
expected though because Colson is
confirmed for the Captain Marvel movies
so I'll explain what's going on and how
this all fits in with infinity war and
Avengers 4 but if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos there's even a
new round of the Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway going on now so first things
first agents of shield Coulson coming
back to the Captain Marvel movie but
what it sounds like is happening because
they didn't give too many details like
the simplest explanation is usually the
correct one the Captain Marvel movie
takes place in like the early mid 90s
Coulson Clark Gregg would have been
about 20 years younger at that point is
just a younger version of the character
who's still working with shield because
we know that Nick Fury Maria Hill are
going to be in the movie but the funny
thing about Clark Gregg though is that
if you look at pictured him from the
movies that he was doing around that
time about 20-25 years ago he looks like
this literally the exact same as he
looks right now at the Black Panther
premiere earlier this year no special
effects are necessary you don't have to
use the special d aging technology they
use for Robert Downey jr. during Captain
America Civil War when they were doing
that barf scene that's how it we should
happen by nearly augmented retro framing
or barf God I got to work on that
acronym I'll talk about plot but even
more important they're bringing
guardians of the galaxy characters into
the Captain Marvel movie so they confirm
that Lee pace is gonna return as Ronan
the accuser in Korath who was played by
Djimon Honsou now remember at the time
of guardians of the galaxy he gone full
extremist like he was about as crazy
easy - ever been in the comics so I'm
guessing this younger version of the
character might get a slightly better
arc than he had during guardians of the
galaxy
call me terrorist radical zealot
because I obey the ancient laws of my
people decree and punish those who do
because as a villain he served his
purpose but I felt like that could have
been a lot better like that was during
the era when Marvel villains just
weren't written quite as good as they're
being done now the reason why he wants
to kill the Nova Corps and everybody on
Sand R is retaliation or what he sees as
the atrocities visited on his people
during the kree-skrull war so this does
confirm that the backdrop for the
Captain Marvel movie will be the
kree-skrull war albeit very different
from the comic book version if you've
ever tried to read it it's really
convoluted is very twisty it's meant to
be this political thriller while at the
same time being a war drama the main
character of that is Marvel the male
Captain Marvel so he comes to earth
disguised as a human and starts teaming
up with the Avengers but it kind of
turns into this backdoor secret invasion
storyline like a proto version of what
would become Secret Invasion that was
more of a Marvel line wide thing but
during this original crease scroll war
there were people in the US government
that were Skrulls they were trying to
take over the planet the scroll Empire
wanted to use earth as a staging point
ruin and the accuser kind of wanted to
do the same thing I'll be it in a more
overt way like alien invasion destroy
the earth take it over turn it into an
outpost for the Kree Empire which they
kind of did during agents of shield
earlier this season they went to the
future there was this creat overseer who
was watching the remains of planet Earth
for his father who had a really high
interest in it so it was of interest as
a location to the Kree Empire but as for
actual crossover I know like that's the
biggest question is this will this
affect the TV shows because the movies
happening in the past even though
they're bringing Coulson back it gets
really twisty when you try to think
about it too hard so again simplest
explanation is the best Coulson will
show up because it's back in the 90s
he'll still be alive
he'll be a much younger version of the
character so everything will be fine
Nick Fury will have both of his eyes
they'll probably incorporate some of
this secret scroll invasion from the
original Kree scroll war that's probably
where Nick Fury loses his eye last time
I trusted someone I lost
and I don't just trust each other that's
what makes you to normal not a bunch of
guys running around shooting guns last
time I trusted someone I lost an eye you
may have seen some recent footage of her
running around behind the set in her
costume the original version of her
costume this is kind of what it looked
like so by the end of that movie she'll
probably change her colors so that it
looks more like comic-book Captain
Marvel if you didn't know Jude Law is
playing marvel he was also seen recently
on the set we don't know exactly what
his costume looks like but it's probably
a version of the Marvel costume from the
comics but the big thing that we don't
know yet is is how she gets her powers
because the actual origin story is
changing just a little bit so it sounds
like they're weaving her more in with
the kree-skrull war this secret invasion
storyline which would explain why Marvel
has to come to earth to try and stop the
scrolls from taking it over and also at
the same time to try and stop Ronan the
accuser and his crew forces from taking
it over so it sounds like earth becomes
this kind of battleground but that
doesn't explain everything because if
you have this giant alien invasion and
Scrolls among us then how do they hide
any big battles or any big fights that
they have from the public because if two
alien races were warring over our planet
back in the 90s it would be pretty big
news like I don't know how you would
suppress something like that so what
might end up happening is is that you
just have a little bit of this happening
on earth then they go into outer space
and that's where most of the crazy stuff
happens but most of the plot is still
wide open to speculation just the
inclusion of Ronan the accuser Coulson
Nick Fury talking about the way he lost
his eye and sort of the original comic
book storyline you can piece something
together so imagine a version of that
but let me know what you guys think
about this then bringing Coulson back I
think that's so great because otherwise
they were gonna have to use Everett Ross
so I'm wondering if he pops up too but I
feel like if they're bringing Coulson on
because Everett Ross is kind of like the
new Coulson who pops up in everyone's
movies they won't use him but the thing
about that is that he's an Air Force
pilot Captain Marvel was an Air Force
pilot so there's just like a couple ways
that you can sew all this together the
larger Marvel Universe so everything is
still connected technically there was a
WonderCon panel recently where the
agents of shield people were asked
point-blank how is infinity war
going to affect the TV show if the TV
show continues assuming they get another
season it's not canceled we sort of
blaze a path dr. strange introduced
magic and all of a sudden we can have no
stridor on our show the guardians of
galaxy are introduced and all sudden
we're in space so we're just waiting for
that movie to come out so it can open up
a whole new playground for us they
didn't say anything specific about plot
points they made it sound like they have
no idea what happens during infinity war
and if they incorporate that into the
plot of the TV show it won't be till
they start working on the scripts for
next season because the same thing
happened during Winter Soldier with the
hydro twist like they actually started
working on the TV show in the writers
room said that they largely did not know
about the Hydra twist during winter
soldiers so they're like wait a minute
we just started doing a TV show based on
this organization that has now been
effectively destroyed in the movie
universe how is that going to work so
you started to see some of the problems
with trying to cross over TV shows with
the movies in the Infinity war directors
also said that there were so many people
from so many different movies consulting
on infinity war that to try and bring in
a bunch of other extra teams on top of
that to consult would have been almost
impossible they just didn't want to have
to deal with a billion different people
giving their input so better to just
kind of push it off into the distance
and let the TV shows incorporate the
movie's plot however they wanted to so
from the movie's standpoint they're
totally fine with what the TV shows do
that involves movie stuff but the movies
are never meant to reference what's
going on with the TV shows so hopefully
that explains a little bit about movie
TV show crossover there'll be a bunch
more Marvel stuff dropping later this
week so leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments congratulations
to triva you're the latest giveaway
winner please private message
me so I can hit your contact details
there'll be a new round when I post a
new Marvel so while you wait for
everything click here for that new black
order trailer and click here for the new
Deadpool trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]